Uh, what, what's the, uh. That's hot now. I don't even know, dude.
I don't even know Kodak black.
That's it? You're 14. You listen to Kodak black. That's it.
I put my heart on my lid.
Dude. I put up a thing up about how I can't remember what it was,
but I was like, I wrote up, I wrote something that was like, Oh,
I was talking about music.
It was the post I did on Instagram about how I was like rapping.
I love hip hop of today.
And I basically was rapping over and I was just doing that.
[Inaudible].
So, and then somebody writes, Oh, you're one of those guys.
And you know what I have to say to that? Your, right?
Oh.
Dude. I'm not, not one of those guys.
I hate.
That. Vivid. The
[inaudible] Hey, y'all K
Be www digit.
I don't know.
Like, and then, but there's people
that will be like, yo, he's talking real. That's the that kills me.
Um.
What do any of these things mean? I'm old,
bro, to be honest, I don't think Kodak can ever make a bad song.
Like if you agree, like somebody thinks that
And then somebody else writes on God, I'm a like of this comment. What? Okay.
Okay. Why you swear to God for that?
Look at this. If you're reading this, I hope you never go broke again.
Edit if you're broke. I hope you get rich. Thanks bud.
You just did nothing.
And some guy writes what happens if you're broke already? Huh?
I guess that was before the edit.
This chick Kodak can have beef with TEI or even Trump and I'll still listen to
his music. That's an odd one.
Wow.
I mean, he's got such a fan base. That means family is way bigger than mine.
So I guess I'm the idiot. I made it.
I don't get it. Cause anybody could do this. That's the thing I don't get
and producing the music. Cause then, okay. But he's not though. Right?
He's just rapping. Anybody can do this for real. And I know people are like, no,
but they can't but you can. Yeah, you can. I can do that. I can do that.
I can do exactly. I can do that. That's it
I'm caught at black.
If you like how in a rail it'd be like, how on the chair?
Whenever I had my heart interfere and it was a gardener beer that's that's ill
as, dude. I'm fire. I'm fire.
I mean, look at this. Look at this dude. This is just for, this is just off.
This is just off the top of my head, dude.
This is just straight up off the top of my head,
pop in the jail. You're going to tap in his, in it for gripping it today,
missing, missing the, dropping the krill.
So we put wrapping us real quick in the pot,
in the kitchen before him just chopped.
And we took into flown in which digging the straight to the top with foul
and the grail with the pocket chair Margolin,
the parking sucks to suck in the book and it jumped another guy,
corn up cam just him at Jordan Bram kicked up,
rip up Whistler ice, hot chip prop.
I got pancakes.
I hot ripping a chip and a channel syrup on pancakes and mail.
We're going eat there and chill. We're going to it out real blip in a PIP,
in a pill form made as CHAM stuck in the sucking.
Got your big muck in the flipped up chicken flip-flops
dude. I that's it, dude.
[inaudible] that was fire
[inaudible] I'm Kodak black.
Um, excuse me.
Black.
Dude. I rap. God.
It's it, dude.
Wow. I actually surprised myself with how ill that was
Ripping the [inaudible] shipping and sometimes I'm just kicking it back.
Just low. It just, just kind of chilling dos, not even really trying to
[inaudible] and then also what if I have my eyes closed there?
I actually have my high schools or what if I open my eyes and my producers were
gone when afterwards.
[Inaudible].
They're just like we quit, man.
That's the worst thing I've ever heard in my life to even talk about.
I put my heart and my lyrics. My mama told me she hear it.
I'd done seen death in effort. Only for God. It must be cut off.
Our home is the envy. I can't say that part will change for a penny.
Hang by my seven. Got Manny. All right. You know,
That's funny, man. Like people actually these lyrics are really deep.
I mean, obviously I'm making a joke. I'm, I understand. It's more.
He's actually trying to put like, dude, I put my heart in my lyrics.
He's the first guy ever to say that? No, my had told me she hear it. Okay.
All right. I done seen death in eight ferret.
Literally every rapper says that only fear God and my spirit.
I mean, so many times cut off old homeys that envy.
I mean, this is about every rap song is about this so far.
And people are like, God, that's deep. Okay.
And by the way, I'm not a hater.
I'm talking to because of what Kodak black did about the Nipsey hustle.
That's why. Cause that is not cool, dude.
The lowest kind of guy is the kind of guy that did what that dude did for Nipsey
house when he died. And he was like, I'm a holler at his girl.
That is the most boy cook.
That is the worst. Somebody in your
Industry dies.
And you want to holler at his girl because you think she's fine or fly your, uh,
your, your, the, in my eyes. That's the worst kind of guy.
That's the worst kind of guy. So you're a cook.
And that's why I'm talking about all this. Otherwise art is art.